good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday we just
it doesn't have the um that it usually
does no because it is friday and we
should be celebrating but i'm just
feeling like
so
exhausted like i feel like i've woken up
every day this week like really hoping
that
things for jews in america would like
de-escalate jews around the world choose
around the world excuse me
and i just woke up today and it was like
the worst it's ever been and i just like
had a full breakdown because it's like
it's so scary to be jewish in a time
like this and you kind of like are
inclined to just ignore it and like hope
it'll go away but
it's getting so much worse and i've
already cried twice today so i'm just
warning i know
people hate when i cry on the podcast
but like i probably am sometimes you
just gotta let it down sometimes you
just gotta let out it's just like a
terrible feeling to like wake up and be
like scared to be jewish
and like and have like a [ __ ] up
thought like
um it's like terrible to say but like
you wake up and you're grateful that you
don't like look jewish you know
because like i mean i don't wear my
jewish star necklace every day but like
i've never
once felt uncomfortable wearing it like
that's a huge privilege of living in new
york and living in a
what's supposed to be like a wonderfully
progressive melting pot of people
and today i was just like walking to
work and i'm like oh my god i've just
never like been aware of my jewishness
in the way that i am now because like i
know two people
who are currently in the hospital
because they were attacked for being
jewish
and of course it's terrible when it
happens to anyone but when it happens to
two people who you know personally like
it's just it's it's just like
indescribably upsetting yeah and
i don't know i feel like we're just
coming off of this like really great
year for social justice
but it doesn't feel like it includes and
there's just like no energy
yeah for us and the energy is
on the other side it feels like yeah and
honestly like i can't even stress this
enough like
yesterday we've all been you know
posting about and keeping up what's
going on in the middle east and
yesterday
they agreed to a ceasefire and that's
like wonderful
but there's things going on in our own
country and like it feels like people
are just ignoring it
and i think we should like we should
focus our energy on that because
as much as we all think we're experts on
the middle eastern conflict we're not
but like
there is stuff we can actually do in our
in our city and like
for it to be happening in new york and i
know it probably sounds like so silly
ten blocks from where we are right now
like it's one of the most densely
populated jewish populations in the
country so it's like
it can happen there yeah where can it
happen
yeah no i think growing up jewish like
we're always fully aware and like we've
learned in school and throughout our
lives like the perils that the jewish
people have suffered and it has always
felt like
america is the exception like where you
are free today who you
are and i feel like candace from real
housewives of potomac oh my god you are
like with your corner um and it doesn't
feel like that
this week it doesn't feel like a safe
haven it it feels like
at best you're silent and at worst
you're coming for us like yeah
it's it's a horrible feeling and i feel
like as jews we feel so alone in this
and like i i also feel like not only do
i feel alone i also feel like scared
to speak up for my community because in
some way it like
devalues another community and that's so
not like at all what i'm trying to do
and it's not okay to hate on anyone
regardless of their religion no matter
who you are or where you're from but
we can't like ignore the fact that it's
happening to jews right now
that can't exclude the jews right but
for for
centuries it has and it does and and
that's just like
literally our cross to bear literally
i'm
like and i think a lot of people are
like so you grow up learning about it
this is what i was saying and you feel
like oh you know we we are in
a time of of the exception and then
you're like oh no this is the oldest
hatred and it and it cloaks itself in
different names and the verb
that's thrown around it it's
anti-zionism no no it's anti-semitism
um you probably don't realize this from
the graphics that you're seeing
but zionism is a beautiful thing it's
not a bad word
it's not a bad word to be a zionist it's
not a dirty thing so to be
anti-zionist is just a like a
more palatable way of being anti-semitic
i think in this day and age i think
throughout history
anti-semitism has always cloaked itself
as something else
you know whether it was in the crusades
and where the hebrews then were the
semites in in nazi germany you know
we're going to put the jews in ghettos
because they have tuberculosis they're
sick and diseased yeah it's always close
itself in some sort of like social
justice
and it's not and it's the same thing
over and over again
and i understa i can imagine that it's
really confusing for people
who aren't jewish who don't understand
what's going on and are like
think that they're helping who really of
course but you're hurting us
this is a tale as old as time and
you got to wake up i think one of like
honestly like a breaking point i had
yesterday was i saw an instagram story
from
an in like a not a hugely popular
influencer
who literally posted a graphic of
jews in the media and like how you know
all these
hate crimes going on are staged because
look who owns the media and i was like
that like actually took my breath away
because that is like textbook nazis i'm
like that was so crazy
and and that person is being applauded
and that no
islamophobic for supporting the jewish
community and that's so not what it is
at all no and like that person that
you're talking about would call
zionism nazism which it's like it's so
twisted i saw a graphic and these are
the types of graphics i'm talking about
where it's like please don't take them
at face value
not ones that are stating facts ones
that are like i saw one that was like
zionism is white supremacy
no matter no matter how many times you
say that or post that that is
not true no group has suffered more in
the last century at the hands of white
supremacy than the jews yet today
we are somehow the white supremacists
make it make sense no and i think like
one of the things that really
bothers me and i think maybe a lot of
people are like well you know
you guys might be overreacting because
of course like even in a perfect world
there's always going to be people who
hate
the black community who like just always
just going to be bigotry like that's
just sadly a fact they're always going
to be people who wait jews
so i think a lot of people are like this
might be like an overreaction and i
think what a lot of people don't
understand is like
technically we grew up in what's
considered like the jewish diaspora
right like the greatest time to be a jew
ever post holocaust
jews have never had more freedom we have
our own country the only jewish state in
the entire world like
so we really grew up so privileged like
not really understanding
how bad it could have been and but we
also grew up like with grandparents who
either
who survived the holocaust so there was
always this like
in all of our education and our culture
and in our religion there is this like
thought in the back of our mind like it
can never happen again but it's always a
possibility it's always a possibility
and you grew up with grandparents who
like
you know never let you not finish a meal
because they didn't have a meal for five
years so like
it's it's so ingrained in our trauma and
so we're always constantly living in
fear that like it will happen again
and so for those who maybe don't
understand like why we take it so
seriously
that's why because like it's so
just like we we wake up every day and
like it's always
constant part of our thoughts i feel
like and up until these last few weeks
it's always been
you know jews we never forget but it
feels like
they forgot what they've forgotten it's
more imminent
than it's ever felt yeah and so
and i just feel like if the least we can
do is is is speech
and so if this were any other community
going through this right now we would
say the same thing which is at our
jewish toasters we are here for you
we feel what you're feeling we feel
alone we feel scared
um but we're here yeah
and just like i like literally saw the
scariest thing in montreal there's like
a service
to walk jews to temple this weekend like
with a bodyguard like you like sign up
before
like where are we living montreal's like
one of the most jewish
cities i've been there it's wonderful
yeah
it's it's just like very upsetting and
what's even more upsetting is like
some of the the messages i'm getting
like people who are just like genuinely
upset
that i'm talking about this like are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah like if you
if you want to come at me for
posting about what's really happening in
new york and making it about the israeli
palestinian conflict like that's on you
like you need to look in the mirror and
check your anti-semitism because
honestly what what is happening in new
york right now
and all over the world is a direct
result of what's going on in israel
but like we need to focus on what's
going on here like literally people are
like taking their yamas off and hiding
their necklaces under their shirt
yeah like that's so not okay no
so i just really wanted to cry on the
show today
well anyways i don't know how we pivot i
just
i feel like we've just been sort of like
putting our best foot forward all week
like just wanting like that's what we do
we cheer people up and yeah but we're
just like not super cheery
it i feel like has reached a fever pitch
last night and this morning
just every day i roll over and i'm like
it's a lot
it's a lot to wake up to and and we feel
no support we do not feel supported and
that hurts
more more that's me and ben were talking
about it before bed last night i'm like
i don't know what's crazier
the fact that this is even happening
because it's like so
1930s like i'm like is it crazier that
this is happening or the fact that like
literally nobody cares because you
always think when you learn about the
holocaust you're like
how did all these people not do anything
and it's like you can't imagine a world
where like literally the jewish
communities
in your country were rounded up at night
and all the people were taken to gas
chambers like you can't even imagine a
world yeah
where are the neighbors like where are
my neighbors call the police take a
picture you know
so you always grew up being like
honestly this could never happen again
because like people would be taking
pictures of it like there's no way
but but people are taking pictures and
nothing nobody cares no but like
also it's so crazy you watch these
videos of one jewish man being beat up
on his way to you know
a pro-israel rally and there's all these
people
beating on him filming themselves
they'll like run and take a punch run
away and film themselves like
as if they're doing something
commendable it's literally black mirror
that episode yeah
um but it's not funny no but even videos
like that like i've just seen people
online
it's it's like well what was he doing
yeah well uh what did he say or like
oh i think those are actors like are you
i can't like that is so
yeah dumb i saw ben posted like a
ignorant
as he at best dm and he was
the person was like you guys brought
this on yourselves oh
i can't victim blaming at its finest
also just like a really weird caveat
is um somebody sent me something on
instagram today like
totally random but like how when you're
speaking on like people's
people always say like your silence is
deafening it's actually a really ableist
thing to say
like no because no it's true like the
deaf community doesn't want to be
associated
with ignorance and i actually really
felt that so i just wanted i never even
thought of that in my life
yeah but now that i now that somebody
brought up like i will never say it
again
okay i just wanted to share it like
clicked yeah no that it makes sense
it makes sense like leave the deaf
community out of this
100 it's not like are you kidding me no
so i actually
just really wanted to share that okay
cool i'm going to keep that in mind yeah
like for sure
for sure justice for the deaf community
like jupiter's head don't bring them
into don't bring them into this
okay well i feel like i feel like i feel
good
yeah we said what we said and now we're
gonna do what we do and that's deliver i
guess we could get right in is there
anything else you want to share
um yeah i think i have seasonal
allergies okay at the age of 26 i do
believe i have officially developed
seasonal allergies i've just been
feeling
a little groggy all week um and i've
heard from my instagram community that
it is possible to develop late in life
allergies so that's just like a new
thing with me
allergies are really bad this year you
can see the pollen like falling from the
skies people think it's sometimes
when we sit into our show that it's
snowing outside but it's dead ass just
pollen
right so it's not your fault that the
allergies came for you welcome to the
club
they came hard for me yeah they're
coming for you
yeah but so is everyone else so get in
line yeah okay i guess without further
ado
where are you he's right there sleeping
being a perfect angel
thinking about how he can help the
rising anti-semitism thinking about it
here are the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
scentbird have you ever had someone come
up to you and say you smell amazing what
perfume you're wearing
whatever scent you may be wearing you
have good taste and you know what you
like but your great taste is also
expensive
excuse me expensive and you end up with
a shelf full of half used bottles or
you've been wearing the same two
perfumes for years
because going out to buy a new one is a
hassle but with sun bird we have found a
way to have great taste and mix up our
fragrance routine
without breaking the bank whether it's
tom ford gucci or versace
cenber.com keeps me smelling good month
after month
so i've tried a lot of different
perfumes from um scentbird because
that's literally the point
melanin goats i didn't even know that
they made perfumes because i've only
used their
lip balm which is amazing and i'm just i
i love it i've discovered so many new
fragrances and the best part
is that basically semper is a
subscription service that gives you the
opportunity to shop over 600
brands they have a really flexible
subscription so you can skip a month
without any penalties
but the best part is that you don't get
a full bottle because if you don't like
it then you're stuck with this big
bottle of perfume or cologne that you
don't even like they send you a 30 day
supply and they carry brands like prada
gucci versace
and if you love it the next month you
can get the same one you could try
different one they're very travel
friendly they come in these great
compact cases travel friendly because i
feel like whenever i'm going to a fancy
affair it's when i'm traveling but then
if i'm just if i'm not checking luggage
you can't bring perfumes
red bird has you covered if you're going
to like destination weddings this summer
scentbird has literally saved my life on
like weekend destination weddings and
it's super affordable you can try
a new designer fragrance every month for
just 16 and with an exclusive
offer just for our listeners you can get
30 off your first month today
that's only 11 for your first fragrance
go to scentbird.com and use the promo
code toast
for 30 off your first month again that's
s-c-e-n-t
bird.com for you to try your first
perfumer cologne for just 11
jolas sign on
smell amazing i was stifling a sneeze
okay first story casey musgraves says
she was dying inside before a split from
rust and kelly she said i felt broken in
a new interview with elle for the
publication's june july 2021 issue
on newsstands june 8th the 32 year old
golden hour singer spoke about her
ill-fated marriage
to ruston kelly if you would have told
me the night of the grammys hey
in two years you're going to be divorced
and have a whole nother album written
i would have been like [ __ ] off no way
she said who's she's releasing her
next studio album this year very
exciting
yeah i mean obviously i was so excited
to read the tea in this article and like
see the photos but i was also just like
excited that she's doing press because
that means like
an album is done it's on the horizon
we're gonna get a release date we're
gonna get a single
soon so we're back in like a casey
musgraves era and as someone who's kind
of been participating in all the years
before it was cool
i'm very excited about this i'm very
excited about this she said that the
album is going to be um very like
inspired by weezer daft punk and magic
mushrooms so i feel like it's gonna be a
little different
you know i wouldn't um i don't know that
doesn't sound like a good descriptor
weezer beverly hills
i don't really think that's like my
particular vibe okay i mean i think
casey will make it your vibe i think
casey actually like if she really tried
super hard and sat down and tried to
write a terrible song she couldn't
yeah so i have all the faith in her the
looks from this
shoot were sickening we saw a little
butt crack so
i'm excited legs for days she also
explained to elle that while her
marriage to
russian started off strong things took a
turn for the worse once the pandemic
kept them isolated at home together for
months early last year she said
i could have coasted for another couple
of years just not paying attention to my
feelings or not really dealing with
some things but the extended time at
home led her to question herself she
said why did i make these decisions how
did i get here how can i prevent myself
from getting there again
why do i keep choosing the same kind of
people she said i felt in many ways on
top of the world in my career but in my
personal life i felt like i was dying
inside i was crumbling
i was sad i felt lonely i felt broken
yeah i mean i think we all
like people who follow casey and rust
and like had like little inklings about
how like they were like
never together never photographed
together never posted them together
um and at one point i really firmly
believed like they just really wanted
their privacy
but that gut feeling you're always right
yeah i don't know sometimes like it is
it is
nice when you know celebs keep their
relationships
private but um in hindsight those were
all probably signs
yeah and i think the sign is like when
you're when you're comfortable living a
very public life
with all parts of you except for your
relationship that i think people who are
private about their whole lives
including their relationship like that
tracks
but i feel like casey like shares a lot
she's very active on social media she
went to the kardashian christmas party
and like her husband was just not part
of any of that so
yeah i think the fact that her whole
life was kind of in the spotlight except
for him
made us all question you know what was
really going on but i think the way she
talks about
her relationship in covet i think a lot
of people can relate to like you can't
run from your problems when you're
quarantined with someone when you're
they're staring at you in the face she's
probably saved yourself a couple years
they probably if
if the pandemic hadn't happened they
would have just kind of mulled along
until it was like unavoidably
problematic yeah definitely so i'm
excited for this new casey era i didn't
know that that was what was happening
but now i'm so thrilled me too i'm ready
for it me too
are you ready for our next story yeah
floribama shortstar nilsa prowling gives
birth to her first child
reality star nielsen gave birth to her
first child a son named gray allen on
thursday at 1 56
a.m prompting influencer claudia ashrae
to go
on a tangent about names like gary no no
first of all i love nilsa i'm so happy
for her yeah i think she's a great
reality star she's giving me major
snooki vibes just kind of disrupting the
whole house with the first baby like
it's a
it's a major shift um and i love laura
bamashore
but the reason i like i saw her post and
i follow her on tik tok and she's been
making so much premium tik tok content
like
40 weeks pregnant because she's been
pregnant forever
um and when she posted her thing i
thought it said gary
allen and i'm like gary allen that is a
grown businessman's name like a lawyer
for alan allen and alan like i was so
confused and then it just like
it kind of started this thought process
in my mind because of course there are
names now we consider to be old because
a generation ago they were considered to
be young and now like every susan
carroll bob
and barbara we know is an older person
yeah but like at one time like
it was a young person's day they were
the chloes right so now what i'm saying
like
in 30 years everyone is going to have a
grandma sarah
or like a grandma rachel no but rachel
and sarah are classic biblical names no
you're right so in 30 years
everyone is going to have a grandma
jennifer yeah and then jennifer like is
going to be for like
gen zier's or whatever comes after gen z
they're going to be like
the most grandma name ever like yeah
susan yeah
so just let me think and then people
were like coming at me because like
apparently i have an old person's name
do you i don't i mean i do know that i
do actually know a few people with
grandma claudius
so i just wanted to make that known but
like when i think of claudia think of
claudia schiffer
and i think claudia like a fabulous
latin goddess like
maybe i'm just narcissistic but i think
claudia's a fabulous name i think
claudia is a fabulous name but they
didn't say it wasn't fabulous they were
saying that it was
um i think claudia's a fabulous young
name i j i think claudia is
not young or old i think it's too rare
for it to have been pigeonholed into one
age demo
i agree that's true actually you could
have a baby claudia now you could have a
grandma claudia that's
to me name goals right versatility
no and timelessness and that's why like
at the end of the day i'm not going to
come for the rachels and the sarahs
because like
those names are thousands of years old
and they'll be around for thousands of
years after us yeah
sarah rachel and leah are like the
biblical names and what are the men's
names isaac abraham
isaac jacob moses moses
he said to the name moses okay i'm into
you know of course his biblical legacy
yeah but not really into the name moses
for a young boy
like where's the beer okay maybe it's
too much of a legacy to
live up to because for us we follow the
old testament obviously and like moshe
was like the whole book
like he was like literally like the main
character yeah and i just
and like he really led the jews out of
egypt into
canaan like he was kind of like a big
deal and i don't know i feel like it's a
lot of pressure to put on a young boy
yeah but it's also you know could be a
good omen yeah of course of course i'm
sure people look at it no but what if
you name you know your kid moses and
then he ends up to be like a degenerate
you know
yeah that's like was it the name i will
never know
okay but so you said on your story like
that you've been seeing people like with
these names of
of old yeah have you been seeing that
yes in certain
in certain groups i'm not gonna ask you
to share of course i just was like okay
but you thought she named it gary but
she didn't no i thought she named it
gary and then it just led me on this
thought process i'm like there are
people who like wake up and decide to
name their kids carol
yeah i don't think there's like that
many no but they exist and like that
what
that was just like weighing on me okay
i'm glad that you shared it
do you have any baby names or you would
never share them i would never share
them shayla
i would never share i would never share
them on the show um
yeah but i don't i don't have like i
have an idea of names but i don't have
like the name don't you also love to
know like what people's names were
supposed to be
yeah like my name was supposed to be
alexis or victoria which now
after being a student of royal history i
would have taken victoria yeah but what
about
being a student of the bachelor yeah and
yeah all it takes is one person who you
don't like to like have a name that you
like
to ruin it for you yeah i had a name i'm
not gonna say it but i had a name
growing up that i
like adored and i met someone with that
name and i will
literally never use that name
yeah i feel that what was your name
supposed to be was it always claudia
yes i people have like stories margo's
name was supposed to be grace i don't
have like a pre-pre-name i was always
just like i was born
stunning and they were like you have to
be claudio your model claudia schiffer
it was on the magazine cover
right next to the ben they were like are
there any other famous claudia's
famous claudias like where's claude
monet
oh i mean my name's sake i grew up being
like yeah i'm glad you jennifer but now
cloudy shippers are relevant like i want
someone oh well claudia jordan
love her um she's not like that famous
though okay there's a list of famous
claudias but you've never heard of it
that i've not never heard of oh
claudia soluski yes she's like a little
prettier than me just a little
i i'm looking for a claudia that i never
yeah it's honestly it's like it's almost
like the universe is begging for
claudia to become super famous i'm on my
way universe
yeah no it's a good name to claim yeah
that's the heart are there a lot of
famous jackie's
or jacqueline jackie o jackie schimmel
jackie schimel that's what i'm named
i don't think there's any like super
famous jackie oh jackie chan
yeah but you could be the female there
are famous jackies for sure but i i also
like when someone has the same name as
me like i don't even realize do you know
what i mean oh i feel like i
really have never taken the time to
realize that jackie schimel and i have
the same name oh wow really i guess you
haven't either
like if that question makes sense you
both are honestly jackie's like a really
fabulous name like i've never met
someone who was named jackie who isn't
like elegant
and refined oh thank you so much schimel
is very
elegant again yeah for sure okay jackie
chan
jackie gleason don't know him jackie
robinson of course
jackie avancho the opera singer
yeah the young girl yeah she has a great
rendition of someday at christmas check
it out
someday at christmas okay this website
[ __ ] sucks
i just want to say um no but like when
you
i mean like jackie kennedy onassis isn't
even
on these lists wow that's like the
jackie
well it's so funny because like you know
ben and i
ben is a very jewish name it's actually
just a very everything name but like
we like i would say once a week we're in
a room with someone who's also named ben
and it must be hard for ben to like not
feel his like individual
like individuality yeah no but i don't
think he suffers from not feeling
individuality no me neither but what i
was saying is like i never find myself
in a situation like that but a few weeks
ago when i went to a bachelorette party
in the hamptons there was someone else
named claudia and i have to say i felt
very territorial
especially because she knew more people
at the bachelorette party so if someone
was calling claudia it was almost
never for me damn and so i felt like a
loser like i felt like the losery
claudia yeah you probably were
that's how i feel when there's another
redhead in the room oh that makes sense
do you mean redhead is in hair color or
redhead as in
uh podcast listener reader of reader of
redheads
um no i mean it's in hair color but
that's of course
okay ready for our next story yeah
prince william is slamming the bbc after
an
inquiry into princess diana's panorama
interview he said my mother was deceived
this is a really crazy story that's like
20 years too late but here we go
prince william and harry are reacting to
the official inquiry into circumstances
that led up to their late mother
princess diana's bbc panorama interview
in 1995. in a statement released on
thursday williams strongly criticized
the deceitful way the interview was
obtained
and defended his beloved mother he said
i would like to thank lord dyson and his
team for the report
i believe that's the dyson report it is
welcome that the bbc accepts lord
dyson's findings in full which are
extremely concerning
that bbc employees lied and used fake
documents to obtain the interview with
my mother made lured in false claims
about the royal family
which played on her fears and fueled
paranoia displayed woeful incompetence
when investigating complaints and
concerns about the program
and were evasive in their reporting to
the media and covered up what they knew
from their internal investigation
so long story short it has come out
investigation has proven that um martin
beshear who diana did the interview with
like
falsely gave her false information and
false context under which she did the
interview which
and this interview was like constantly
referenced right he was iconic the
fallout from it like the divisiveness
between the family like
i think it made everything worse yeah
and it played on her paranoia as william
said and so
finally 20 years later a reminder that
the media is trash
yeah but like i don't know i feel
conflicted about this because what i
actually i just love
i love how william and harry like love
their mom so much and they're constantly
even after you know years after her
passing
are just trying to you know uh protect
her legacy
so i appreciate that like william
doesn't want this like
uh what he believes to be like
manipulation of his mother of her in
a hard time to constantly be exploited
but also like
and as sad as it is like you're a public
figure you do an interview like that
[ __ ] lives forever
i don't know in the words of claudia
ashrae justice is on the table
it i when i said that like that was not
the right phrase i meant to say
what did i mean to say what was i
talking about when i said that yesterday
i have no idea and it was a few days ago
i don't like justice is up for grabs or
i don't know but
so justice is up for grabs and i also
like touch the table when i say so i
understand that like it happened and you
know
move on i guess is what you're saying
but like no not move on but like
that is just a part of being a public
figure like do
do i do not to say i'm even on the same
page as the royals but like are there
pictures of me on the internet that i
literally would literally pay any amount
of money to be destroyed of course
i hear what you're saying so but i i
feel confident i agree with
i appreciate justice and context and
hindsight
whenever whenever we get it yes i do
appreciate context because of course
i've seen that interview and i don't
even know
what he's talking about like apparently
there were forged bank notes or whatever
yeah that proved that this guy was in
with the peeps and
just makes you think so yes you're right
like media manipulation is not okay and
it's it's never too late
to give to give context and like show us
what really happened that i agree with
yeah
i think that's always an important
lesson especially today especially now
like with the royal family like they're
just like not having a great year in
terms of press
oh yeah i was just talking about media
in general oh but i'm just talking about
the royal family like
oh yeah this is just like one of the
things because i think that interview
for a lot of the diana stands like was a
a
caused a chasm yes chasm that's a great
word
against the royal family yeah are ready
for our next story little art news
a little art news that's brought to you
by booty by bray bands oh yes they love
art
broody by bray bands founded by fitness
instructor kelly bray bands is changing
the athleisure game with its high
quality durable leggings and inclusive
approach
booty by bray band's leggings sculpt
your body highlight your curves and will
take your workouts to the next level
with the perfect amount of compression
and support
they are a brand that prides themselves
on their inclusive approach they
eliminate numbers from the shopping
experience because numbers should never
define us
you can experience the booty by bray
band's signature croco skin material
which is what you've been working on for
the last like three weeks
and it's everything of the sort it feels
so good to work out and things stay in
place stay where they should and when
you look in the mirror like you like
what you see
right which is so rare when you're
working out um the black croco skin
leggings are the perfect black leggings
that every woman needs in their life
they are designed to last a lifetime
you can also shop them in biker shorts
which are on uh
now up as a spring summer staple so if
you want to check them out
shop now for 15 off using the exclusive
code toast at bootybybraybans.com
that's booty as in b-o-o-t-y by bray
bands b-r-a-b-a-n-t-s
dot com code toast for 15 off check it
out work out in style treat yourself
treat yourself okay next up a little art
news a long-lost van gogh
masterpiece venga vangog
has been discovered by a new york city
collector we love
just like double departed yeah i don't
know he found it at an obscure country
auction
but it is um that's crazy an iconic
piece
would he pay like 20 for it oh i don't
know the piece is called offers 1890
it's in its original condition inside
and on the back by
quote vincent it's a once-in-a-lifetime
find and then van gogh museum in
amsterdam has requested he sent it to
them for immediate authentication
okay but the people are they gonna send
it back um
yeah yeah they're just authenticating it
but like but when if they just have it
like when they just put in their museum
and steal it
i think they would have i would be
nervous about like sending you wouldn't
trust the van gogh museum no of course
i have the one thing they want and
undiscovered why the [ __ ] would i trust
them
totally the piece about i would i would
fly there with it and oversee
the entire process but i wouldn't just
hand it over yeah no i feel that i think
you're on to something 100 percent
they'll say no it's not authentic
because they gave him back
and then it's not authentic let us keep
it no no they'll give them back they'll
make a fake they'll give it to him and
say it wasn't authentic right and then
they'll keep the real and then like they
found one too
yeah yeah they found one too the piece
if authentic was likely painted in the
last two months of the famed artist's
life wow van gogh shot himself in a
wheat field in july 1890 possibly in one
of the fields that appears in the
painting
so this is like a stunning yeah this is
a big a big find
wow the art world is quaking the art
world is quaking and and
you know i'm excited for them i wonder
that they have what to quake
how much do you think it's gonna like
sell for millions
yeah i think like maybe like hundreds of
millions i don't know
but first of all it'll be exciting and
like
what do you think costs more of van gogh
or by costco i think van gogh
and it's also you know i for a second i
was like wait is van gogh the one who
was just alive because apparently
picasso is like from the
1900s like shut up you know this yes
like you do was alive picasso recently
is that not that crazy picasso died
around not well i'm gonna give you the
exact date
in 1973 pablo picasso don't you
just associate him with like the fifteen
hundreds yeah okay one was van gogh
van gogh was eighteen hundreds which is
something that you guys know it's fan go
i just like i
can imagine the comments being like you
really thought of that gog
no we didn't we went to van gogh um 1890
that's still like not that far away no
but like that's
that makes more sense yeah yeah but
we'll never forget that picasso
was just like it was like alive in the
seven woodstock probably like that's
crazy
yeah yeah well so i think then that the
van gogh piece would be more
valuable because it's older right yeah
yeah shocking
shocking stuff i wonder who's gonna buy
it then we can like look into their
forbes you know
yeah see if they have any single sons we
can add them to the list
we can add them to our list um yeah so i
was just going to ask you have you been
hearing about nfts
of course well then ben did like a whole
thing on the podcast about it oh okay
cool
cool cool um i was just learning about
them last night i do think it's like
kind of silly
i mean ben explained it to me and i was
like well why would someone pay
some of them are going for hundreds of
thousands of dollars for
a collectible digital thing when
literally you're on the bidding website
you can just screenshot it like
it's so dumb like how will anyone know
that like i bought the nft or if i just
screenshotted it from the bidding
website
like it's so silly and then ben was like
hell no then ben was like
well you could say the same thing about
you know you can go to canal street and
buy fake louis vuitton or you can go to
57th street and buy a fake
real louis vuitton most untrained people
would assume that would not know the
difference so
okay i guess that's a good point but i
can wear my purse out i can fill it with
things it serves a purpose
i don't know what a digital picture
serves for me bragging rights
and then i saw emily ratakowski sold for
140 000
i'm like okay well honestly this is not
that much like for emily ratakowski like
i was just like i was kind of
unimpressed by the amount
okay so i'm i i don't have one
i won't be bidding on any and i don't
really understand it
yeah same but i'm starting to learn so
i'll keep you posted on my findings
are you ready for our fifth and final
story is it the final
story
[Music]
okay our fifth and final story is a
little shipping news because i don't
know about you but i kind of like missed
the suez
oh by the way i miss the suz every night
and i'm like oh my god
please someone gets stuck in the sweat
that's a joke i know it was a crisis
our story is like something that
pertains directly to us and us
and us swez lovers not that i missed the
suez i just kind of missed like
the time when we were all just like
talking about the same thing and we all
had a common goal like
free the sweats and there was no like
two sides of the switch no and it was
just like we live in such
that i think we actually said this when
we were reporting on it like we live in
such divisive times like nobody can
agree on anything but we can all agree
on like
we need to help the suez you know yes i
agree well
new york harbor has welcomed a ship
larger than the empire state building
the biggest ever ship to dock at the
port authority seaport
wait can i ask a really dumb question
the [ __ ] is in new york harbor
um but it's a hudson river in the east
river okay since it's at port authority
it's going to be the hudson
right there so we're calling the hudson
river new york harbor now yeah i agree
that's
just misleading i just wish we had you
know clarification yeah the largest
container ship to
ever sail into new york harbor again
confusing arrived thursday the crowning
achievement of a years-long rebuilding
effort to bring the port authority
seaports up to modern standards
the 1300 foot cma cgm marco polo
like that's just such a great name yeah
is longer than the empire state building
is tall and stretches over five north
south manhattan blocks
it can carry up to eight thousand
forty-foot containers
it's cargo yeah it's cargo on thursday
included containers of household goods
bound for shelves at stores and
warehouses owned by corporations like
walmart
amazon and lowe's um
okay now that since this is like an
actual like active shipping container
i'm sure it has to go like bring other
things around
but could we still go see it i'm sure
you can go to the
port authority and like watch it can i
say something kind of crazy okay because
like those cargo shipping containers
like they're huge
okay so it's like the size of the empire
state building and all those trucks
have to load up those cargo i just
really feel like we don't have space for
this like
can this be like a long island city
venture i'm serious like i'm just
thinking like
it's wonderful i love ingenuity on the
sea i really do
but like i'm just thinking of like
day-to-day lives from manhattan like
we're already like overpopulated
we're crammed there's so much traffic
like i just really feel like this is a
project we cannot currently take on
and i would like to pass it on to one of
the other boroughs like it's not a
project
per se they're just like dropping some
stuff off well honestly like we need the
stuff but we don't have
like the time or space to coordinate
these drop-offs
well they're doing it like nobody asked
you to lift your finger
no i'm just saying like i don't live
near that area but i can imagine that
the people that do have been severely
inconvenienced like that's just a lot of
stuff
there is a lot of space there but it's
it's actually true there's also like a
garbage jump over there so
i guess that's great all of our
household items are being delivered next
to the
garbage dump yeah i just like want to
see a big ship in the harbor you know
you should go you would love this
cbg sully and dbg yeah tbg is
is his sully like reincarnation well
he's not bad but
like like re yeah like protege
yeah yeah um so i just think that's some
pretty cool shipping news like
we just love ships there was clearly um
a drought in stories
no i saw the story it was amongst the
first and i said there's a big ship
in our harbor and we're gonna talk about
it and our ship is
coming in and you know what it is friday
you might be going to a dinner party
this weekend so if you're looking for
something mundane to bring up you know
there's a lot of controversial things
you don't want the dinner table start
talking about the israeli palestinian
conflict
you should say hey did you hear one of
the world's largest shipping containers
as big as the empire state building just
pulled into port authority today
isn't that a scientific marvel the cma
cgm marco
polo yeah and then you can ask what you
think of the effects on the neighborhood
is going to be
yeah even though that's not the
conversation i'm just saying that is
something we should talk about
yeah yeah i agree and if i have to be
the one to lead that conversation
however uncomfortable it may be i'll do
it
thank you you are so brave that's why i
do what i do okay is it time for tv
recap
it is the kardashians were on last night
and boy did they disappoint um the
keeping up with the kardashians recap is
brought to you by let me give you a clue
brush your brush a brush
chris was singing that who's chris kris
jenner i was watching an old episode she
was singing it
oh that's funny and i was like what is
that from and i remember so girly yeah
um but i just thought it was like a
personal joke of ours so i was like
how does chris know this song no it's
from greece and it's also the official
jingle of bruce the best electric
toothbrush on the market we know all the
toasters have gotten it so far but if
you haven't gotten one yet we have a
great offer for you
if you're looking to elevate your
toothbrushing game if you're not living
in an electric toothbrush you are living
in like another century like we're all
brushing your teeth electrically
and we're doing it with bruce because
it's the most effective electric
toothbrush on the market
and the most affordable and also the
most glamorous like they come in amazing
colors they have a whole line of new
colors
gray mist green dream mauve cloud i'm
really happy with my millennial pink but
i'm thinking i need to get a mauve cloud
brush because it really matches my
aesthetic i think you do here's how the
brush works excuse me the brush
it comes with six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
so if you're looking to brush your gums
if you're looking to brush different
parts of your quadrants
they have all these different settings
so you can get the best brush possible
they also come with a two minute timer
for a complete even clean in all four
mouth quadrants
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
compact travel case
they also come with a subscription
program never forget to change your
brush head again bruce will ship you new
replacement heads every six months so
you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head again
the design is super super sleek the
electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design and it
comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and looks great on your bathroom counter
the truckers for bruce have arrived just
on time
thank you these new colors are only
available for a limited time so get them
before they're just a distant dream
get 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit and
the refill plan
when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast.brush.com
sign on brush your teeth get you get
your breath
okay i have something to admit you
didn't watch i was catching up [ __ ] i
had four episodes to catch up on
yesterday and i could only get through
three and then it was 11 45 and i had to
go to sleep and i'm so sorry tell me
what happened
okay what happened let me think um but i
watched the one where they announced
that they're leaving so yeah we have oh
okay
they all could recap all there was like
a little bit of juicy drama with uh okay
so apparently there was like some sort
of kerfuffle between kourtney kardashian
and one of kim's nannies
and so kim sat down with courtney and
wanted to talk about it because like
kim's like i don't like to
go through staff like i'd like to have
staff for a really long time so i'm not
going to fire this nanny
based on what she said but like i want
to hear from you
and it got really heated really fast
because basically like i guess that
annie like made a joke to saint because
saint was like being a camper
like well what's gonna happen if i do
this and whatever and then nanny was
like you're gonna go to jail
because you know you just say things to
kids to but courtney's like not that
type of mom you know
so saint complained to courtney they
were driving to idaho or something i
don't know
saint complained to courtney and
courtney explained to the sisters that
like
her and saint have this type of
relationship where if saint complains to
her about something someone did
saint wants courtney to reprimand that
person in front of saint so
saint feels like courtney has his back
and i'm so no i'm not a parent and i'm
not really not anyone to judge anyone's
parenting
skills but it just feels like saint is
in charge like saint's running the house
and i was like it's a really weird
parenting method but again
i'm not a parent so i don't know what
it's like but also it's not parenting
it's emptying
no no no oh sorry did i say saint sorry
i meant wait was it rain yeah okay sorry
okay because i was like sorry about
these are getting involved sorry sorry
sorry i'm sorry it was raining she's
totally
rain rain is going to jail rain okay so
it sounds like brain is in charge
yeah so it was just like whatever so
courtney then took it upon
herself to reprimand the nanny in front
of the kids
and when when they got home the nanny
was like hysterically crying
to kim like packing her bags thinking
she was gonna lose her job and when kim
asked her what happened
she basically said that like courtney
was so derogatory to her speaking down
to her like in front of the kids like
she said she's never been spoken to that
way in her life and courtney just
recalled the incident
completely differently like it was two
people who experienced the same thing
literally explaining it in two different
languages like they were completely
different
and then it got really heated really
thank you on camera no and they kept
um bleeping out her name okay so kim was
the representative for the nanny
versus courtney in in courtney versus
and the people in the people vs kourtney
kardashian and the nanny
got it so and the conversation got
really heated really fast
and then kim like threw out like an
insult you know when you're fighting
with your sisters you're just saying
like the most hurtful thing you can say
she's like well that's why you can't
keep any
nannies and no staff like wants to work
with you or whatever and courtney went
away and she started crying in the
bathroom it was all about the boundaries
again
unhealthy toxic negative whatever and
they eventually worked it out kim came
over and apologized
and just said she was trying to like
push courtney's button but then they
evolved into like this [ __ ]
storyline about how they need to have
a negativity jar because they're all so
negative to each other and so when they
sit down it's like what are you wearing
and actually like they do do that a lot
but it was not enough for a storyline
then the other storyline was that
chloe's moving out of her house
she's building a house from the ground
up um so she was and her house already
sold but she's not going to be in her
new house for like a couple months
so she had to move to a rental and the
whole thing was like tristan running
around courtney's house
sorry tristan running around chloe's
house getting all the candles she likes
labeling his pantry like copying all the
things she has in her house so that
while she's in the rental she'll feel
comfortable you know spending time at
tristan's house with true and it was so
stupid because it was so fake like him
running around photographing like
the lights on her pagoda that honestly
sounds like cute and good it does but
like literally we just heard what like
two weeks ago that he cheated on her
again so i just don't know which
tristan to believe hashtag who is the
real tristan thompson okay i just want
to say
i i didn't keep up fully with that last
cheating scandal
but i feel like they were saying like
that they think that that girl is lying
like that there's i didn't even i didn't
i didn't see that be like suing
no courtney chloe had actually dm'd her
and the girl put
chloe's dm on blast right but that still
doesn't mean i don't know i don't know
what to believe
no i like if history
has taught us anything it's like we
don't believe that they're watching this
tristan who is not literally
so it's a question who is a real truth
in thompson i don't know so that was
like a really dumb storyline
um and then the other little storyline
was like the kids have never seen
keeping up with the kardashians and
kim and scott were like they're gonna
watch it one day like don't we want it
to be like with us
so they took them on this like little
tour of like old places they took them
to the townhouse that chloe scott and
courtney used to live in
and like they couldn't have cared less
and kim and and scott were like dying
and the kids were like acting like
animals and they had to leave
um but then they like set up like a
little theater they spliced together
like you know important moments from
every
episode of the last like 20 seasons and
made all the kids watch it in the
theater and everyone was so happy
it was a really dumb episode honestly
sounds amazing no it was really silly
it was super silly okay and then just
when you talk about it's like the last
few episodes like they announced that
the show is ending like
black book nori's black look which was
so exciting and i love that they and i
love nori's black book i love that they
love it
me too and they're not offended by it
and they're like they can laugh at
themselves yeah because like
nori goes in sometimes you know the
dream kardashian hope fund
is the funniest thing ever i know they
didn't mention that no of course not
because it's so mean but it's
hysterical um
but then they were like harping so much
on the show ending and it was like so
sad and we're not gonna see each other
and it's like
but what about the deal that you just
signed yeah no like i don't i'm sure
they can't like promote their new show
on their old show like there's some sort
of ethics
around that but um but it's literally
just going to be the same thing but on
hulu so it's like
scott yeah they haven't told us what the
hulu show is
i think it's going to be the same thing
i really do but see i was i went on the
nuts getting
off that podcast yesterday we were
having this conversation because like it
makes no sense like part of the reason
why they're ending the show is because
literally nobody can film like
kim and chloe have to go to the hospital
for their backs being broken for
literally putting the show on their back
for the last five years kendall doesn't
want to film chloe doesn't want to film
courtney has her boundary issues and
like
mj is suddenly the star of the show like
so why does moving to hulu fix that
more money more money
but i don't really feel like it's ever
been about money um no but i think that
they could have even like yes they have
issues with like nobody wants to film
but they get the show out
you know it's not very good i i still
was teaching it
if it weren't the kardashians i would
have stopped watching this show years
well no
this this season two months ago
i know it's like not good but i still
like just enjoy it
i just enjoy watching it like even
watching kim try and learn dances from
addison like kim
is a nice dancer no she is really uh not
a good dancer i enjoyed watching it i
wish she would have gone through with it
i wish he would have gone through with
it too because i was thinking i'm like i
never saw that tick tock so
yeah where did it happen also the
storyline with the lifeguard i found to
be
he was cute so hysterical he was so cute
everyone like didn't know how to act
i just like enjoy there's some things
that i enjoy and the other times
i'm like yeah no it's like silliness
honestly whatever like scott's involved
with it's always like the worst
storyline no offense to scott he
deserves better
no but for me it's like whenever they
just keep saying the same thing like
chloe and her surrogate
i thought it was going to be really easy
because for kim it was so easy but for
me
i'm a little bit more like it's
repetitive they say that
like five different times throughout the
episode i get it it was easy for kim not
easy for you micromanage
got it yeah got it very repetitive and
they talk so slow and like there's
really just no substance
but i live for them and i love the looks
i love the looks yeah exactly so
so it's worth it yeah it's a fun time i
really tried my best i'm really sorry i
didn't even read yesterday like i was
really trying i can't believe you didn't
even tell me
i know i just didn't want to burst your
bubble like there's enough going on i
thought that it couldn't
be fine i thought i'd wait um so nothing
else was on last night right just
kootka and now it's friday and so we
must acknowledge the space that we're in
we must
we have two days of alarm free living in
case you forgot a week works
and we must go forth and prosper with
this alarm free life living you know
go to the edge of a cliff norma kamali
is
is rooting for you we're all rooting for
you we're all rooting for you
um i'm just so excited that it's friday
me too even though it doesn't feel like
a friday
no i know because we just have a lot on
our minds and usually friday is like i
can't be bothered to think about
literally anything even remotely serious
yeah i totally agree but we're gonna get
into that weekend headspace and we're
gonna make it a good one
thank you all we all thank you for
listening to the morning toast we really
all do thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fastback stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up if i may
i filmed my what i eat in a day vlog
yesterday it should be up today i'm
gonna put it all together i was like
really enjoying like just watching it i
thought
i'm just so interested um no but it
turned into like
what i do in a day also because i eat
all day so that's what i'm doing
um so that'll be up today at patreon.com
morning toast if you're looking for
premium content or you just want to
support your girls patreon.com
toast we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio i
heard
your cat's box also i don't think you
guys should miss out on what's going on
on the toast next week because we have
scheduled some i don't want to jinx it
because like everyone can
us but we have scheduled some
unbelievable guests like
dreams dreams so just keep up with the
morning toast okay
love you guys stay safe this weekend
reach out to your fellow jew and have a
great weekend love you
goodbye